du hast einen weiteren aufreger noch
mitgebracht und der geht um boris palmer
der immer alles anfangs so richtig
gemacht hat in dieser krise als
bürgermeister von tübingen der sehr
schnell getestet hat und jetzt aber auf
facebook sich auseinandergesetzt hat und
dort kam ein wort auch dann plötzlich
auf wo man sich mehr als 100 die
parteikollegen muss man sagen wundern
sich ja schon lange bringen boris palmer
hat wieder einmal deutlich über die
stränge geschlagen
und zwar hat er beugehaft gefordert
beugehaft für menschen die sich nicht
impfen lassen und das hat er nicht etwa
gefordert in einer offiziellen
stellungnahme
oder sondern facebook einfach einfach
mal so in einem facebook kommentar einer
frau beugehaft angedroht und hat gesagt
das sollte für menschen wie sie gelten
menschen die sich eben nicht impfen
lassen wollen und das sorgt natürlich
für für hitzige diskussion und das
überrascht bei boris palmer auch weil er
eigentlich immer einen sehr liberalen
kurs gefahren ist er war eigentlich
immer ein kritiker von lok downs ist
natürlich ein großer befürworter völlig
richtig und jetzt kommt er plötzlich mit
beugehaft aber gab es nicht den
hintergrund dass er eben im netz sehr
stark angefeindet wurde mit grüner nazi
und so weiter und so fort um das war
eine reaktion auf eine anschuldigung
dieser frau nummer zwei absolut völlig
richtig boris palmer schmeiß dich auch
wirklich immer in die heftigsten
facebook diskussionen der zum teil auch
selbst auslöst das ist eine
kommunikationsstrategie er kommuniziert
sehr unverblümt auf facebook zieht
natürlich auch deswegen sehr viele
polarisierende meinungen an dennoch muss
man sich natürlich die frage stellen als
als oberbürgermeister einer mittelgroßen
deutschen stadt alles was man da konnten
sagt alles was man da schreibt ist
natürlich auch irgendwo offiziell und da
wir nichts dienst plötzlich von
beugehaft für ungeimpfte zu sprechen
weiß nicht ob das nicht vielleicht im
gegenteiligen effekt hat und die
menschen eher noch wirklich abschreckt
philipp erde danke